thank you
[Music]
what if we could create any protein or
any biological structure that we wanted
and for it to be biodegradable
sustainable and safe for use
well that is the ultimate mission of
Ginkgo fireworks our biotech company
founded in 2008 by scientists at MIT and
they're using biology to achieve it
how you may ask well by genetically
engineering living organisms like
bacteria yeast and mammalian cell lines
to express proteins or genes of Interest
testing them to select the best ones and
then growing loads of it so that the
desired products can be extracted
in other words synthetic biology
these products grown by living organisms
can then be used for industrial
pharmaceutical purposes as well as food
production and for fragrances
I recently traveled to Boston and was
able to have a little tour around
ginku's building
I then later spoke with taneja a lead
organism engineer at Ginkgo to hear
about what they get up to and how
they're achieving it
we attempt to make biology easier to
engineer that's our motto right and what
that means is that we're constantly
playing with the DNA from the context of
building new products improving on
existing products and just working on
cool science and cool microorganisms to
help us as a community the human
Community live in symbiosis with the
with the environment around us right so
um what Ginkgo essentially does is
caters to different aspects of the
market today it could be food it could
be personal care it could be you know
textiles dies
Pharmaceuticals and it could be
commodity chemicals it could be natural
products and wherever there is a need
for a product to be made by a
microorganism where biology can make it
easier biology can make it safer or
biology could make it faster right so
cheaper faster good quality and safer
that's where we come into picture so
essentially Ginkgo is offering a
platform whereby if I wanted to engineer
an organism to make something instead of
me or me telling someone to spend a
five-year project doing it themselves
and while I'm probably having limited
success Ginkgo can just do it on a much
larger scale using their expertise
and Screen many more different
variations to find the best one for the
product
let's say that as an example I have to
make an apple taste like an orange okay
now the apple is going to remain an
apple but it's just going to taste like
an orange right so in the traditional
setting you have one scientist take that
Apple Tinker with its DNA the plant cell
or maybe Tinker with the seed that
produces the apple and then create
changes in it that makes it produce an
orange-like Essence right now in Ginkgo
what we do is we um we work on several
Solutions at the same time using high
throughput technology okay so uh we have
what we call foundries and we have code
base which essentially is
um like they're two separate units that
work very well together The Foundry is
essentially like
um a unit that that does a large number
of activities using instruments man and
machine work together right so robots
and humans and we run thousands of
experiments in one time right in high
throughput right so you can imagine
robotic arms doing this
day in and day out and several things
and then aside we have humans which are
which form the knowledge base
and data and analysts and computer or
machine learning right
um which essentially thinks the
information that The Foundry generates
makes sense of it creates a code right
um which basically says the next time
you do that experiment you don't have to
start from scratch you can start from a
better starting point right or don't do
this this didn't work the last time uh
or only do this this makes a lot of
sense right so we take all of that
information it's a knowledge base the
code based part of things right and so
we keep feeding back it's a cyclic Loop
right so Ginkgo uses the code base and
Foundry Technologies together such that
we can run thousands of different
versions of solutions to make this apple
taste like an orange and we end up
finding Solutions where you might find
Apples tasting like bananas pears
peaches you know oranges all at once
right and then we use our screening
technology to identify the orange
Essence right the orange molecule and
then know that that's a solution but the
good news is the next time someone comes
back to us and says
hey Ginkgo we'd like to make the Apple
now taste like a banana we don't have to
repeat the experiment we know how to do
it right
so yes that's how we work we play with
microorganisms uh we essentially study
them very carefully ahead of time we
understand how to run those experiments
on them how to treat them
um how to transform them to making
something that they did not do before
right and then once we know how to do
that we can do it a million times
this strategy is effective since it
enables them to Pivot and to do projects
for different needs
so we've worked on creating food
ingredients for Motif Food Works where
we produce ingredients that are
alternatives to actually
um you know you know proteins in the
food space for example we've got meat
ingredients and we've also worked with
you know companies to produce Pita
scents so the the fragrance Peach
flavoring Peach and then we've worked
with companies on commodity chemicals
um I can't actually name exactly all of
them but we've got several
collaborations running we've worked with
Chronos to make cannabinoids which is
highly
sought after in the market today but
like pure versions of the cannabinoids
which have several applications right
um and then we've worked with uh so
we've got food Motif and several other
companies that we can't name just yet
we've got collaborations in the textile
space we've got collaborations in the um
pulp and well let's just say valorizing
bio wastes into products
um so flavors and fragrances
um and then we've got
um work done on commodity chemicals and
small molecules the natural products
Discovery right and very recently
um you'll see that we've also
um had the this this you know
acquisition with uh uh with with the
team in in Basel which is new screening
technology
um with Switzerland it's fgn and uh we
are constantly and we look out to to
enable better Technologies within the
company
um such as screening using encapsulation
which could then be used for any of
these projects because we can run things
in higher throughput
um we've also worked we're also working
on in the agriculture space so we
joining buyer uh so we've we've sort of
uh we're setting up a an agriculture
vertical where basically we um we're
going to engage in and in helping
agricultural products or produ produce
right so yeah so those are some of our
applications and pharmaceuticals so
we've got a big Pharma
um
vertical as well what if it's too
challenging for them to achieve
good question because I'd say that that
most projects that come to us are
extremely challenging because if it
required if it was an easy solution you
could do it with one person in the lab
right yeah with one or two people in the
lab but the projects that kind of
projects that come to us are essentially
those which cannot be done unless you
had a high throughput technology where
you have to run several parallel
Solutions like thousands of parallel
Solutions at once and then determine
down select to what the solution could
potentially be or at least identify what
the bottleneck is right
um and now
um having said that I would say most of
our projects
um always see Milestones which see
technical successes right so basically
um we we Define our projects in a way
that we have small packets of of work
which will achieve um you know certain
technical successes and moving along
those parts would essentially help us
determine and the customer understand
whether we are moving in the right
direction
right
um and so um what I would say then is
that if we don't achieve certain
commercial successes because of
whatsoever reason meaning that the
market changes the consumer Behavior
changes or the customers need change
right
um that happens quite often you know
more uh it happens quite a bit I mean of
of maybe 10 programs uh it's interesting
I mean there are no statistics right now
but our goal is to commercialize every
single program that we have right that's
that's what we do we we just want to
help the customer get into the market
right uh but the path along that can
take anywhere from a year to five years
right wow yeah it's very very it's very
much possible Right it depends on what
the customers goals are so if in the
case somewhere along the line we find
out that oh this is not working out this
is not a viable uh uh you know solution
multiple ways of doing it right uh
ginkgo's this is why ginkgo's knowledge
base comes into play We either identify
what went wrong right and pivot meaning
that we we switch out our solution so
maybe change the organism maybe change
your path or maybe change the the
solution
um space of of enzymes or something like
that or alternatively we pause and we
tell that we respond to the customer and
say guys this is not a this is not a
viable solution and you need to rethink
about how we are
um you know creating this ingredient or
or maybe there's a different way to go
about this this uh this product right so
a negative result is also a positive
impact for a customer because the more
dollar you spend
in running an experiment that data is of
importance so the rule is fail fast
right if you have to fail fail fast and
have a solid reason on why that happens
and if the reason is not solid at least
have a hypothesis that we can test so
that's our that's and and of course the
uh the water that Ginkgo always will
make in is if there is a solution we
will attempt to find it but if if there
is no solution then fail fast
so it is good to fail as it can still be
informative for both Ginkgo for future
projects and for the companies that they
work with as although you can go is
known as the organism company it seems
the key organisms are the other humans
that the team at kingke work with to
create Innovative products
so our customers teach us more than we
can ever know ourselves
and so um I think that's the biggest
biggest thing uh with Ginkgo this this
collaborative environment where we make
it work for our customers I think that's
that's the part of it that that I think
is super important and that anyone in
science student lose sight of it's
amazing to practice and understand the
nature of events of the nature of things
happening because that leads to some
Creative Solutions that leads to
something that's magnificent to
understand but also to apply right
um and so this is why our motto is we
make biology easier to engineer because
engineering is about application right
but with the ability to grow anything
one must also be cautious about what is
made and that is used for goods not evil
and that the long-term implications and
impacts are well thought through
we have a risk assessment group and ehns
safety group to ensure that we are
ethically and safely using our platform
um because biology can be dangerous
biology is very powerful right so we
just need to ensure that we
um keep sight of what is right and what
is uh good right
um and and use our platform in a in a
with Integrity essentially so there you
have it this is what GK by works is up
to hope you enjoyed this video thank you
to my patreon supporters and thank you
for listening